nos preguntan cuántas focas hay contamos
una foca dos focas tres focas hay tres
focas comprobemos la respuesta
es correcto hagamos otro problema ahora
nos preguntan cuál caja tiene 18 focas
vamos a contarlas son muchas focas bueno
aquí tenemos 123 focas no no nos
acercamos a 18 para nada
aquí tenemos una dos tres cuatro cinco
seis siete ocho nueve focas no son 18
focas seguramente está este pero vamos a
contar las 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13
14 15 16 17 y 18 focas seleccionamos
esto y comprobamos nuestra respuesta
es correcta hagamos otro problema nos
preguntan cuántas ovejas hay veamos 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 y 17
ovejas
entonces tenemos 17 ovejas ahora si
comprobemos la respuesta
es correcta